when they printed all this money they're
telling American people that trust us
modern monetary Theory but what's great
what the trick is is they're not
investing the money in infrastructure
programs production and things that's
monetary theory is that you put you
print 10 trillion dollars you put it
into stat factories so that you start
producing Goods that are worth more than
the 10 trillion they're not producing
the things they're just putting it in
bank accounts look let me let me keep it
real simple about modern monetary for
every one of your listeners it's got a
little brother or a little sister
let them just spend whatever they want
regardless of how much money's in the
family's bank account How's that gonna
work
it's an unmitigated disaster and mom's
gonna be mad somebody's getting a
spanking I still believe in spanking I
got kids I spank my kids just whatever
you know social media can get mad at me
but it is what it is somebody's in
trouble
you cannot just spend money
without any controls on what comes in
nobody can do that